the history and culture of the
mandalorians is one of the most
fascinating aspects of the star wars
universe
and the sagas mandalorian characters are
among the most iconic in all of science
fiction
but just what makes them so special this
is the untold truth of the mandalorians
mandalorians originate from the outer
rim planet of mandalore the planet's
citizens are divided into houses and
clans that have often been at war with
one another
despite sharing a common creed in code
but a person doesn't have to be born a
mandalore to be a mandalorian since they
often recruit orphans from other worlds
and teach them their way of life
including their culture creed and code
the mandalorian in the disney plus
series was a foundling
having been adopted into the culture
when he was young a history that led him
to take pity on the alien child he had
been tasked to retrieve
in the show's early episodes and
although mando is human
mandalorians can be any type of species
what ties them together is their spoken
language
and their strict code realistically
virtually anyone or thing can become
part of the culture
as long as they're willing to learn the
way of the mandalorian
reserve some for the foundlings as it
should always be
the foundlings are the future this is
the way
before the live-action series boba fett
was the most recognizable mandalorian in
star wars
even though he isn't actually a
mandalorian at all as attack of the
clones makes clear
he is actually a clone of the bounty
hunter jango fett while jango tore bow
by the ways of the mandalorian
he didn't grow up surrounded by the
mandalorian culture it might sound
complicated but mandalorian director
dave filoni and show runner john favreau
cleared things up in an interview with
ew favreau said
our guy is a mandalorian and we
definitely explore the culture of the
mandalorian
while filoni added boba fett is not
mandalorian not born of mandalore
he's more of a person indoctrinated into
it into the way of life
and gets a hold of the armor boba fett
is also a straight-up villain
being a bounty hunter who's in it for
his own personal gain and while mando is
certainly capable of lethal violence
it's clear the direction of his moral
compass is rather more complex
it's mentioned in the mandalorian that
mandalorians aren't as common as they
used to be and that's a real
understatement however while the empire
wiped out most of the mandalorians in an
event known as the great purge
in their heyday the mandalorians were
some of the most feared warriors in the
universe
they worked as bounty hunters and
mercenaries and were ruled over by
leaders who held the title of mandalore
their violent tendencies quickly drove
them to conquer other worlds including
concord dawn django fed's supposed
homeworld
eventually the mandalorian's warlike
ways attracted the attention of the jedi
and the wars that ensued between the two
went on for centuries
they came at a great cost too in the
final battle between the jedi and the
mandalorians a cataclysmic event
transformed the surface of mandalore
into an inhospitable desert
forcing the mandalorians to abandon war
and focus on rebuilding
eventually the mandalorians
reconstructed their cities under sealed
domes which powered citizens from
mandalore's harsh environment
a civil war followed during which
mandalore's warrior class waged battle
against the new mandalorians who
advocated for peace
ultimately the new mandalorians won
transforming mandalore into a pacifist
society
sateen cries took over as the duchess of
mandalore and the more militant factions
were exiled to concordia one of
mandalore's moons
during the clone wars the pacifist
duchess sateen cries became the target
of assassination attempts because of her
beliefs
obi-wan kenobi and the other jedi
dropped their differences with the
mandalorians and came to the aid of
christ but their efforts fell
short against the death watch a
terrorist group led by the concordian
governor
pre vizsla vizsler who wanted to revive
mandalore's militaristic culture
teamed up with darth sidious former
apprentice maul to take over the planet
cries was overthrown and when the dust
settled maul sat on the throne
but moore's reign didn't last long on
the eve of border 66 and the destruction
of the jedi order the former padawan
ahsoka tano and an army of clones
traveled to mandalore to stop maul
and free the planet the ensuing battle
known as the siege of mandalore
saw maul's regime come to an end and
inadvertently paved the way for the
imperial occupation of the planet
as with all great empires the
mandalorians live by a kind of pyramid
structure
with the most elite warriors at the top
and the least powerful at the bottom
on top of the pyramid sister mandalore
the leader of the mandalorian people who
was guarded by the protectors
upper echelon mandalorian warriors who
helped to maintain balance and peace
among the people
under the protectors of the houses which
are made up of various clans who vied
for power over many centuries
while these wars helped to make the
mandalorians some of the strongest
fighters
infighting was also one of the reasons
the mandalorian empire fell from grace
their lands were ruined the body count
stacked up and the mandalorians
gradually weakened over time
nevertheless there's no arguing with the
culture this fighting produced
the warriors that continue the
mandalorian tradition remain as
formidable as any others
and tend to be virtually unbeatable in
one-to-one combat
most mandalorians speak basic the
universal dialect that links the star
wars universe together
but they do actually have their own
language too it's called mandara
and while it's not quite as rich as some
of the other fantasy languages out there
it's much more fully developed than you
probably realized mando were first
appeared
in attack of the clones albeit only in
written form and went on to pop up in
both star wars the clone wars and star
wars rebels being spoken out loud in the
rebels episode legacy of mandalore
sukuya elite ran ibiki sabine ran
aranovar
gadetje mevartigar however the language
first started to take shape in the video
game
star wars republic commando which
features an old mandalorian war chant
called vodayan which translates to
brothers all
from there author karen travis picked up
the reigns her novel republic commando
hard contact
includes an extensive mandaea glossary
as well as grammatical factoids like the
idea that mandela is only spoken in the
present tense
since mandalorians believe in what they
call a living history
unfortunately hard contact is no longer
canon and travis has even removed all of
the supplemental information
about mandela from our website still a
handful of mandara words can be found in
fantasy flight games tabletop rpg
supplement
collapse of the republic as well as some
other tie-in materials
including the official star wars
galaxy's edge cookbook
the famous mandalorian armor might give
them their iconic look but it serves a
far greater purpose than just looking
flash
made out of a red substance called best
car mandalorian armor is strong enough
to repel a lightsaber
and can easily withstand a blaster shot
in fact it's one of the strongest alloys
in the galaxy
the insignia in each set of armor also
reflects clan affiliation
and pays tribute to the fallen warriors
of the past but best car isn't
impervious to any attack
in fact during the imperial era the
mandalorians developed a weapon called
the arc pulse generator
which was capable of burning
mandalorians to a crisp inside their own
armor
nicknames the duchess the arc pulse
generator was later used by the empire
against the mandalorians themselves the
mandalorian armor's ability to withstand
the lightsaber has come in handy on more
than one occasion
this is because while obi-wan kenobi and
other jedi stepped in to help save
crisis mandalorians during the clone
wars
the mandalorians and jedi were once
fierce enemies and sure they lacked the
ability to use the force or obliterate
their enemies with lightsabers
but the strongest mandalorian warriors
could easily go toe-to-toe with jedi
knights
these differences didn't last forever
though jedi tend to be reasonable
and they prefer to take the high road
and make decisions that aid the greater
good
and despite being masters of combat the
jedi code does call for peace above all
else
when the clone wars roll around there's
no longer quite as much hostility
between the two cultures
and by the time of the galactic empire
the wars of the jedi and the mandalorian
are pretty much ancient history
of course best car steel isn't the only
weapon the mandalorians developed to
bring down their jedi opponents
in fact many of the weapons associated
with mandalorians were developed
specifically to fight their
force-powered foes
while the mandalorian's unique fighting
style evolved during their many clashes
with the jedi as
dave filoni explains their weapons their
arsenal their technology had a massive
increase once they collided with the
jedi
and found these force wielding people
that had abilities they didn't
understand
filoni didn't just make that up either
referring to the legendary star wars
concept artist who created boba fett's
look filoni says
i've always believed that because that
seems to be something that would be in
the dna of the joe johnston designs of
them as super commandos
at any rate the mandalorian's efforts
seem to have paid off
obi-wan kenobi has enough trouble
standing his ground against django fett
on kamino or dealing with the death
watch in the clone wars
taking on an army of mandalorians and
their prime can't have been an easy task
even for the jedi it's hard to imagine
the mandalorians and jedi ever joining
up together
especially considering their troubled
past and given their rigid differences
it's even harder to fathom the idea of
mandalorian jedi but there's always an
exception to every rule
tarvisla was the first mandalorian to be
inducted into the jedi order
while he joined the jedi order at a
young age he eventually became the
mandalore of his planet
a fitting role for some one of his
capabilities of course every fearsome
warrior in the star wars universe
deserves a distinctive weapon and
vizler was no different hoping to bring
together the best aspects of his two
cultures
vizzler built his own version of a
lightsaber dubs the darksaber a weapon
like that
may have floated in the face of
everything that jedi stand for but it
was perfect for vizsla himself
and ended up becoming a legendary
artifact of the mandalorian people
the darksaber soon became the symbol of
house vizsla after vizsla's passing the
darksaber was kept in the jedi temple
and eventually the members of house
vizsla took the black-bladed saber back
to their home world
and used it to unite the people of
mandalore the dark saber was passed down
from generation to generation and it
eventually made its way into the hands
of darth maul
after that the darksaber somehow came
into the possession of the imperial moth
gideon who's seen wielding the legendary
weapon
during the mandalorian season one finale
pairing mando with baby yoda in the
mandalorian might have proven to be an
active genius for the show's producers
but there's a very real reason why
mandarin in particular has a soft spot
for baby yoda
stop touching things
this is because the mandalorians often
take care of orphans and induct them
into their culture
and of course mando himself became an
orphan when his parents were killed
since history tends to repeat itself
mando rescued baby yoda who's presumably
an orphan himself
it doesn't hurt that mando has seen baby
yoda's force capabilities first hand as
mandalorians are particularly prone to
taking in orphans who show the power and
a willingness to
fight which could be part of the reason
why mando goes back for baby yoda in
chapter 3.
so under the code of the mandalorians
baby yoda is now mando's foundling
just what that really means for either
character however is yet to be seen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you